Ready, I'm ready.
Here in the lab. We're going to make a plastic called Bakelite.
Bakelite was one of the first plastics
that became widespread.
It was made about a hundred years ago for the first time by a guy called Baker.
Baked land was spelled in a quite complicated way with ease and ease.
But the material he invented quite soon became much more
simply called Bakelite. And it became.
It's very popular when people were making telephones and, um,
toys and all kinds of things.
If you remember, we didn't have telephones in our pockets.
There was a telephone in a place of all-knowing usually in the whole of a house.
The telephone was made out of Bakelite and because it was brittle,
if you drop the telephone, it broke. Have you ever owned any bait?
Not that I know of. I think it might be slightly before my time.
Time, particularly the radios,
which in those days occupied the sort of place that TV's
occupy. Now, people used to sit around the radio to hear the news, and again,
they had Bakelite cases.
So we're going to make it. It's actually a very easy synthesis.
It's the reaction between phenol and formaldehyde.
Darren is doing the chemical part of making Bakelite to make real
Bakelite. You have to add so-called wood flour,
which is a powder made from wood,
particularly the part of wood called lignin,
which is what gives wood its strengths.
Have in here. If you can see in there a reaction vessel,
we have the phenol already kind of a,
uh, crystalline kind of material.
And we have here some from all the Heights. So I'm just going to add this in.
[Inaudible] what's that dog, your dog.
Just turn the heat up a little bit.
And I'm going to put in some acidic acid.
[Inaudible] have you ever had this many cameras?
[inaudible].
We're going to leave this for a while,
just so we have a nice intimate mixture between the phenol and the
formaldehyde and, and th that'll hit sit there happily,
and nothing will happen until we add this,
which is concentrated hydrochloric acid.
If you heated it up,
it was then sufficiently flexible that you push it into a mold
and mold, all sorts of objects.
Ashtrays people used to smoke a lot then,
and particularly knobs for putting on all sorts of electrical equipment.
You'd know that the on, off switches, things like that.
So usually
when we do this, nothing happens until we, uh,
after the last couple of meals, I am adding the asset quite slowly.
I think we might be seeing some pink comment.
There we go.
We've made a plastic.
Uh.
What Darren is making is called a phenol formaldehyde resin.
Um, it's, it's, it's tough. It is. Um,
it's quite a tough material.
Well, actually,
I've got a rather crude model down here of Fino.
This is a benzene ring with five hydrogens,
and this is an oxygen atom with another hydrogen on here.
I put this on and it tweaks,
but that's not part of the scientific explanation.
Formaldehyde consists of carbon and oxygen
and two hydrogens, but in the chemical reaction,
the oxygen goes away. And so in the chemical reaction,
which is surprisingly violent and which requires the catalyst,
you can either use a base, that's an alkaline or an acid. In Darren's case,
he used hydrochloric acid because he's really fond of hydrochloric acid.
He used it to dissolve a cheeseburger,
but he used this acid,
which makes the formaldehyde attack,
the Fino I in this position or that position,
there's a called the author positions or the position here para.
And so essentially it joins a whole series of these rings together.
One, four mile, the tide goes in here, then you get another ring.
And so you get to complicated network of these phenol molecules
joined by ch two groups.
And if you look at the chemical structure written down,
it quickly looks like my hair.
Okay. So we're going to give this another go. And, um,
the difference this time is we're going to apply a bit more heat and see if
there's any difference.
What was discovered by Beckland was that this mixture could be molded
and it led to a large number of different objects being made
nowadays they're much better plastics.
And so Bakelite is not used very much.
There are the whole group of people who collect Bakelite objects for the
soldier's sake.
[Inaudible].
We were a bit disappointed actually, because, um,
it's not as good as yesterday's yesterday's we coated the inside of the few
boards with Bakelite and, um,
we don't really know why it's different yet.
So we'll have to think about that one. We do have footage from yesterdays,
so maybe we'll look at the footage again and see if we felt that. Yeah. So, uh,
the quality may not be as cool as, yeah,
so.